Having a Mexican restaurant
in the United States is a paradox.
On the one hand, we have a culture
that despises Mexican people.
And on the other hand,
Mexican food is an integral part
of the American Diet.
Cala is a very different restaurant.
It is a restaurant that accepts everyone.
Cala was completely inspired by Contramar.
In Mexico,
our co-workers are part of our family.
Even with the language barriers,
even the cultural differences,
the bond that we've been able to build
working together,
it opens up doors
and it opens up conversations.
And so we're trying to teach each other
and listen and just connect
because we need to
pull some of these walls down.